[Music]
drew come forward
a chef this is a chicken quiche with
cremini mushrooms baby spinach and feta
cheese
[Music]
unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
well drew i have a huge problem with
this dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
thank you chef
because if you had drew then i would
know how good you are at cooking food
that's bad
i'm sorry chef and when i say bad i mean
michael jackson bad
thank you chef you know how he looked
really really bad at the end of his life
chef
i'm sorry i don't know if you like the
dish or not you don't know if i like the
dish or not
well let's put it this way pat your
knives get out you're off the show
sorry cher
because
you should be working in the finest
restaurant in the world
thank you chef just not any world that i
live in
sorry because frankly drew
i'm jealous of you
thank you sure and your ability to not
give a sh
about what you cook this
is not fit for human consumption no this
should be eaten by a higher life form
with a more complex palette but also an
altruistic drive to save humanity from
dishes like this joking not you just
have to die
[Applause]
so you won't have to endure a life in
which you will never exceed what you
have achieved here today
[Music]
thank you chef
[Music]
in conclusion
[Music]
hey as far as i'm concerned this
saturday night there's not even going to
be a fight i'm gonna mercy kill this old
man derek is very rude person
but soon he will learn manas
i will torture his body
so that his soul learns to be humble
i'm gonna dance around him while he's
trying to hit me with his cane
oh man
god trust me for this fight
god is the teacher
derek is the student and i am god's
instrument
when i squeeze your lungs direct
and you beg me for life
then your heart will open up to the lord
i'm going to knock him out round one
[ __ ]
wait
what are you saying
that god chose him
that
doesn't even make sense really
when you eat through plastic too
when you are paralyzed from neck down
then your family
will gather around your hospital bed
to see the new day
okay you know we just talking here right
i mean
we
we just getting people interested in the
fight because i'm sorry is this crazy
god's lessons
are so beautiful
guys lessons are beautiful i was alright
who put this fight together
this is
what i do if y'all got an actual crazy
person f to me for me to fight well
that's not fair to me
or him
[Music]
what you mean you can't find him
but where is he
yo man where's my manager at steve how's
it
[Music]
today on judge jesse judge jesse turns
up the heat he signed a piece of paper
he gave you the snake then you bring a
snake into the home with two small
chihuahuas i had not been made aware
that the snake would get rid of his skin
and then the sprinklers came down with
the snakeskin room a carpet what what
set up the sprinklers unrelated popcorn
fire your honor
judge jesse has a police officer he
defended the streets
as a trial lawyer objection he fought
for the truth
as a black belt
he mastered discipline
as a carpenter
he learned the value of craftsmanship
as a surgeon he mastered a cool head
as a crackhole
he learned to go days without sleep
and as an announcer he does the voice
over on this show
coming up on judge jesse mr simmons
before you speak i know from experience
that the police have completely
mishandled your case and there's legal
precedent for you to win and any good
defense attorney would have told you
that i also know that obviously the
place where you hurt your back wasn't
structurally up to code mr oyama and
furthermore as a sensei you should know
a man of his skill set cannot do a maiki
yagi you should know that obviously i
can tell by looking at your alignment
that you've herniated a disc someplace
in your l4 or your l5 i'm fighting for
the plaintiff not 2500 2700 mr oyama
thank you your honor you're quite
welcome
[Music]
judge jesse
dusty got a second
no no no no here's the thing here's the
thing okay okay i guarantee you i
guarantee you if you look at obamacare
25 years from now and you look at the
number of enrollees no no no
no you guys
got it wrong you have to look at the
amount of people enrolled in the health
care system and the tremendous effect
that it has on the economy you're
missing the point you are missing the
point what you have to do what you have
to do is look at the tremendous effect
that obamacare is having on the u.s
economy and in addition you have to look
at the government bailouts of the auto
industry in the banking industry you got
it right you got it wrong so wrong you
have to look at the effect on the
banking industry as well as the auto
industry my friend when you do the
bottom line the only conclusion is that
obama is a
disaster are you a republican
yes
i'd like to apologize for this
programming mistake
in the future we will do better at
choosing our guests here on
diametrically opposed
[Music]
we met b-boy joseph in atlanta ga hi
joseph what's up
stop the music
[Music]
has he started
you know i'm pretty sure this is it
[Music]
thank you
yeah thank you yeah i ain't done yet
though thank you joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no i'm
sorry
no
all right
thank you joseph thank you
because you know i ain't got no formal
training no nothing like that i learned
on the streets
that was very impaired as it turns out
joseph so thank you for coming you know
that my mama's on drugs and my daddy in
jail
it's not
not really relevant
born in a coffee can under a bridge
that's terrible joseph that's that's
awful but it's not going to my sister
shot my brother while my cousin beat my
uncle okay now
it's a little bit much joseph thank you
very much but put myself through school
by renting my body out as a heroin
suitcase all right wow i see what's
going on joseph please we we do have
other dancers here today who are waiting
their turn very politely no joseph let
her come on stage let her come no joseph
if i won this competition i could put a
roof over my house cause i got a house
ain't got no roof for real though joseph
just one little thing though don't
do it joseph it was a loud bridge don't
finish that i got hearing damage in this
ear joseph and also in this area the
bridge have trucks go over it just
because the bridge keep it 15-ton hold
it
put it in your mouth
and get off my stage
rated six joe that's a big truck seth
okay joseph please and who
is this oh who is this right here this
is my 12 year old daughter who i raise
all by myself without the help of
anybody else in the entire world she is
my inspiration joseph it doesn't matter
there's nothing you can do or say that's
going to make us change our minds today
that right there that right there that's
her daughter she blind
come on
[Applause]
so i raise them both by myself without
nobody else's help come get your ticket
to vegas
as don's week at the warehouse was
wrapping up it was time to come clean
with his employees actually everybody
uh
got an announcement to me don't nobody
want to hear your bull newbie okay don't
nobody want to hear it i think you will
care about this one so uh gather around
i'm not actually a new employee you can
say that again you a waste of space as
far as i'm concerned can't get another
done in time like like a snail over here
[Laughter]
i am
actually
president of the company
you're on undercover boss
tv show yeah what
in this week
since i've been working here amongst you
i uh
got to hear each and every one of your
stories
it's just about and uh
you know i was just playing right you
know
i was just trying to lighten the mood in
the workplace and whatnot okay thank you
joseph
mill
buddy
you're telling me that your car broke
down and it hasn't been working right
ever since well i want to get you a new
ford explorer
oh my god thank you so much mark that
means
so much to me my whole family died in
one day
thank you huge car crash huge man we
were having a family picnic and then
this truck just came on through and just
killed everybody it chopped everybody's
heads off illinois
you were worried that you were not going
to be able to afford college for your
two two boys and uh i'm starting a
college fund for them both putting ten
thousand dollars in each one of them
this is amazing
i'm so grateful i i can't make no family
anymore because my dick got chopped up
in the accident and now i pee out the
side sometimes i wake up in the middle
of night i just i start to pee let's go
right in my mouth
sometimes poop come out the other side i
don't even know what
dick is in eight pieces
okay you know he just give me a raise i
didn't ask for no kind of scholarships
joseph i'm gonna get i'm gonna go and
get to you right now okay dude i
mentioned i was a prostitute since the
age of seventeen fifteen ten chelsea
seven joseph three chelsea prostitutes
since i was three i was in i was a
prostitute in the womb i do put his pp
in my my mama and they got inside of me
and then and they gave me money joseph's
please man you have been rude to me
since the moment i came here
come on man i mean i was playing with
you dog i knew you was the boss the
whole time man look at this fake ass
mustache that's my real mustache joseph
it really hurt
you're fired get out of here i can't
understand what
get out of here
i got a i got a rare condition that make
me unlikeable oh you don't trust him
pants
lance you've been in the urinal with me
you see me in the urine i am sorry but
do not engage
in pieces joseph leave lancelot it's
true so then give me a little bit of
money no it's not going to happen can i
have a joseph
he did he did joseph leave norman out of
this
who's norman the foreman norman the
foreman that's his name
i know that
i work intimately with him no you don't
you're fired all right i'm going all
right you're out the door with you
joseph i am sorry about that uh
is he gone
okay uh
betty
when you told me
that your father passed away it hit me
because my father passed away but my
dick got chopped up though joseph my
dick got chopped that is so
disrespectful joseph what are you doing
i thought you left joseph like gristle
off of thanksgiving turkey you're lying
and i got a crystal dick joseph that's
wildly inappropriate straight meat
gristle just hanging out here right here
right now you can't see does that
coming up you know you have so many
siblings and just to know
that we both share
a familial bond and that there's nothing
that can take that away but my dick got
chopped up joseph
where how did you
what's the matter rich in the next
episode steve urkel turns carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious but it's
hilarious come on i'm an actor gene this
was supposed to be about me and my
family no but you know after that after
that first death spot with steve urkel i
mean america fell in love with him man
we had to make him a regular and you
know hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we gotta play ball
bubba don't you dare bubble up me gene
now last week steve used his
transformation machine to turn carl into
a car and drive him around the monaco
grand prix come on how many times are
you gonna use this transformation
machine this was supposed to be a blue
collar cosby show now you turn it into
goddamn quantum leap who writes
i i couldn't tell you even if i wanted
to okay maybe we got like 21 writers up
there okay you know what i'm saying
reginald but you and i both know that
they don't decide what happens in the
show okay we both know who decides what
happens in the show two weeks ago steve
urkel used his invisibility ray on carl
and i wasn't even in the goddamn episode
it was just my voice yes i know i know
regen i'm sorry i apologize will never
happen again then steve used his voice
changing ray to turn carl into a
high-pitched nerdy voice who do you
think provided the voice for that don't
get too feisty on me now reg let's not
go down that path okay oh we're going
down that path gene in a couple of weeks
harriet eddie laura grandma aunt rachel
little richie and the other little kid
are going to get teleported to another
dimension and then steve injects carl
with his own dna so carl turns into
another steve urkel that's two steve
merkels and no family on a show called
family matters how the [ __ ] does that
work listen listen ranch i don't want to
tell you orklemania is unstoppable okay
he's a phenomenon there's nothing we can
do about okay it's up to
him no no no no no i'm an actor i'm a
factor i am a real actor i need richard
the third i was in true west with
sherman helmsley i was in die hard damn
it
steve urkel
you will suck steve urkels if he wants
you to you will suck
you understand he has our bread and
butter you mother
i am high on cocaine i'm a master gene
i've done more cocaine than you weigh
mother i'm gonna tell you what you are
wrestling johnson you're a
pawn in that nerd's game
do you think i have any power over let
that monster dust any power at all
i am the senior
vice president of development for the
american bruh
gene
gene
gene what's become of eugene
[Music]
i
[Music]
am nothing
do you know i don't know what you mean
by that team but you're scaring me no no
don't don't do anything crazy gene
everyone does too much coke sometimes
but just what are you going to do with
the gun gene what are you going to do
we can talk this through uh okay
the king is dead
long live the king
did i do that
[Music]
jaleel jaleel
there is no jaleel
only steve
it's always been steve
give me guys
forgetting something carl don't you come
near me stay away from me here could
have all been so simple
carl
just say your lines
and take the money
what are you doing
i i
i can't control
am i doing this
no no
no no no no no see ah i'll do anything
you will do what i want on family
matters
yes
of course steve
[Music]
see you on set carl
get out of my house
oh
[Music]